okay white player is called so far ahead
from Germany come let's check does it
have a name in them okay later we should
be five line in the Sicilian not the
most exciting choice but a very good
line also i would recommend this for
white players if you don't really want
to go into the the open sicilian with
all the sharp lines own but you rather
prefer to ya play play a healthy center
base to game so to say then it's it's a
good idea to to look into the Bishop b5
lines on some very solid for white and
you can still hope to play for an
advantage it's not done it's not without
ambition so to say okay so somewhat
somewhat weird but it's really is
beginning to look like on like a Spanish
game like a rule no pass
case playing a cook a form to complete
development yeah but term as a one is
hanging the 75 is not not threatened
okay
yeah age six or so typical move here to
pick our own further maneuvers for
instance rook e8 Bishop f8 to improve
the rock maybe play g6 Bishop g7 later
and in this some kind of maneuver there
should be 50 always some is some
somewhat annoying k Bishop d3 i'll go
Knight a5 you would like to drop to a 2
but you need to at least reckon with
taking on yeah it just goes back you
need you need to check taking so Bishop
f8 so useful muth yep
yeah take here and then maybe play t5
next yeah now be five is maybe maybe
hanging the normal way would be d5 now
also a checking before okay I could
spend a minute to calculate this but it
looks just looks just like the move to
play so I play it wrap here and then I'd
be far so b5 hanging now and see to
hanging just think think for a bit yeah
okay could be five
yeah with the ticking here he was able
to to save the night but the lie down
doesn't have really a great Squires to
go to or about let's say queen e seven
is Queenie seven covering this one and a
threatening c7 why didn't I didn't see a
knight c7 here ok I've got rook c8 yeah
okay okay rook c8 I thought this would
be ok just because of c2 hanging
ok
okay a citizen is not really a great
square for this piece hmm don't think
that taking theirs is the best move can
play night before then bishop d6 looks
like the positionally correct move
taking away all the squares this is also
interesting of course or where does he
go then on to a two and then look okay
eight maybe
spend too much time on this black is
good anyway um with with both move so I
should have played this quicker okay
let's pin this night now
the idea we should be 54 bishop c6
time warning
adium Bishop d8 now now somewhat lost
the thread with the time going down the
cap you should pay for now also yeah
yeah I spoil this yeah of course my mind
once you just gone now okay now I'm
better again but I'm low on time of
course
I got the better minor piece own only as
usual in the one time check check check
check check check check growl are drawn
yeah I needed to take the draw with just
10 seconds yeah this this was this was
just bad play by me I should should
really get something out of this
position it looks terrible this should
be fine rook c8 computer already gives
us as winning yeah this is no surprise
really yeah Bishop c3 between a 226 yeah
is certainly good this is somewhat
somewhat less less convincing
Queen d8 now wins for black minus 5 is
always always cool to say okay this also
wins surprising Quincy aid now winning
yeah it always seems to assumes to win
material quincy aight of course as c2 is
saying yeah while this was really a crap
game i mean i could have won multiple
times ok this is still better a 7 now
still winning yeah but I've got 36
seconds zone yeah the soul pin
configuration on the air force was just
terrible by white but some simply
shouldn't should allow this year so
grateful black yeah I should have won
this game really bad play ok next one